do the truth
[Music]
that sounds different did you change it
well I change it a little bit why I just
play it the way list would have played
it if he'd altered box version play that
again
play what again the thing you played
outside oh you want me to play the thing
I played outside please
[Music]
I can't believe you changed it again oh
I changed it a little bit yeah why I
just played it the way brews own he
would have played it if he'd altered
lists version and what is wrong with box
the way Bach would have played Bach
never wrote it for the guitar in fact
right even sure before last
[Music]
it's young bark he dedicated it to his
brother
there's nothing heroic in going down
fighting if it can be avoided nothing
even remotely patriotic in death or
glory if the odds are firmly on the
former nothing inglorious in trying to
shorten a war that we are clearly losing
losing your rubbish still Europe is lost
and before our forces are wiped out
completely now is the time to negotiate
in order to obtain the best conditions
possible Hitler will not insist on
outrageous terms he will know his own
weaknesses he will be weeded when mother
lesson be learned when something learn
are we more dictators must be woo
appeased God given emits privileges
before we learn you cannot reason with a
tiger when your head is in its mouth you
can practically see it from here what
home there are 400,000 men trapped in
one place on a beach their backs to the
sea the enemy closing in all around them
and it's just a matter of time before
they face surrender or annihilation and
the fact that this story does not end in
either surrender or annihilation is what
makes it one of the greatest stories in
human history and one which I've been
wanting to tell that for quite some time
okay there's no hiding from this son
come on
Hey hang on Chris Chris I want to
introduce you to some principal this is
David and Marsha Wincott Ronald and
Celia Jeffries Haruki Tanaka and Jessica
and Friedrich Walton
- Rene sir River behind do you find the
VIS African Omega has more advantage or
disadvantage in the modern world it's a
tough one yeah I don't know man hey yo
man they were asking me about the
african-american experience maybe you
could take this one oh well well I find
that the african-american experience for
me has been for the most part very good
although I find it difficult to go into
detail as I haven't had much desire to
leave the house we've become such home
bodies yes yes yes but even when you go
into the city
I've just had no interest the chores
have become my sanctuary
[Music]
you know sorry man
I want to go where culture is like any
organ I research or at least Connecticut
or New Hampshire where writers live in
the wind of those schools anyway mom
can't even pass your driver's studies
you wouldn't let me practice what else
you work or though or the way that you
don't work you're not even worth state
tuition Christine my name is Lady Bird
well actually it's not and it's
ridiculous i greased eight you won you
should just go to City College you know
with your work ethic just go to City
College and then to jail and then back
to City College and then maybe you'd
learn to pull yourself up and not expect
everybody waiting around like I did for
you this was an ambush Alma to what
purpose
this is not I know it's not going as I
expected I didn't mean these things to
come out I'm sorry but it was meant to
be nice what did you expect I wanted
time with you I wanted to have you to
myself you have me all the time
no you're talking about I don't I depth
there's there are always people around
and if not then there's something
between us something between us what
some what distance when did this happen
what happened to make you behave like
this is it because you think I don't
need you yes I don't
well that's very predictable of you
[Music]
so can I ask you a hypothetical question
oh dear I don't like hypothetical
question no I don't think you're gonna
like the real one either do you have the
papers not yet
oh gosh oh gosh because you know the
position that would put me in you know
we have language in the Prospectus yeah
I know I know that we bankers can change
their mind that's and I know what is at
stake you know the only couple I knew
that both Kennedy and LBJ wanted to
socialize with was you and your husband
and you own the damn paper since the way
things worked politicians and the press
they trusted each other so they could go
to the same dinner party and drink
cocktails and tell jokes well there was
a war raging in Vietnam we're talking
about I I'm not protecting little you
notice former Secretary of Defense
Robert McNamara the man who commissioned
this study doesn't part of protecting
the paper
[Music]
[Music]
how was your trip time to security just
one number please security food security
for security
[Music]
hey there Mildred you didn't happen to
pay a visit to the dentist today did you
no aah I heard no oh so it wasn't you
who drilled a little hole and want a big
fat Jefferies big fat thumbnails no no
huh
I said of course not you'd rip the
holder the dentist doesn't know I didn't
I thought it was kind of funny myself
but he wants to press charges so we're
gonna have to bring you in I'm afraid
[Music]